Two names stand above all others in the annals
of all-time action stars — Sylvester Stallone
and Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Both men are icons whose careers started very
differently, but ended up following remarkably
similar paths.
It's no easy task deciding who's ultimately
better, but we're going to try.
This titanic battle wouldn't be so tough to
call if Stallone and Schwarzenegger didn't
have so much in common.
For starters, each guy headlined some of the
best action movies of their era.
They also played some of the most famous characters
in film.
For Stallone, there's perpetual underdog boxer
Rocky Balboa and the PTSD-stricken, one-man
army John Rambo.
For Schwarzenegger, there's the killer robot
from the future, the T-800 from The Terminator
franchise, the Predator-killing Major Dutch,
and the sword-wielding Conan the Barbarian.
Given their similarities, it's no wonder they
had a heated public rivalry for years.
From Schwarzenegger throwing shade in movies
like Twins and to Stallone literally throwing
a giant bowl of flowers at Arnold during the
Golden Globes, it's clear that during their
heydays, the two couldn't stand each other.
While they're friends today, you better believe
their rivalry still exists low-key.
Sylvester Stallone is mostly associated with
shoot-'em-up, one-man army action movies,
which even at their best have never really
been associated with high art.
Nevertheless, Stallone does boast artistic
bona fides that Schwarzenegger does not.
In fact, Stallone has achieved the pinnacle
of Hollywood's artistic accomplishments — the
Academy Award.
Stallone has been nominated for the Academy
Awards three times – for Best Actor and
Best Original Screenplay for Rocky in 1977,
and for Best Supporting Actor for Creed in
2016.
This makes him one of only six actors to be
nominated more than once for playing the same
character, alongside Cate Blanchett, Paul
Newman, and Al Pacino.
While Stallone didn't win Best Actor or Best
Screenplay, Rocky ultimately won the Academy
Award for Best Picture.
Though Stallone has Schwarzenegger beat when
it comes to cinematic awards, Arnold surely
takes the cake when it comes to non-cinematic
awards.
Schwarzenegger is a world-class athlete who's
considered one of, if not the, greatest bodybuilders
of all time.
In many ways, he's the Michael Jordan or Tiger
Woods of his sport.
While experts can quibble about who's the
best based on this stat or that, nobody can
deny that Schwarzenegger brought more attention
to bodybuilding than anybody before or since.
That said, Arnold's career isn't just hype
— he truly was the real deal.
From the time he first picked up a barbell
back home in Austria at 13 years old to finally
hanging up his speedo in 1980 at the ripe
old age of 33, Schwarzenegger won over 20
bodybuilding championships, including three
Mr. Universes, and seven Mr. Olympias.
Along the way, he literally wrote the book
on bodybuilding, 1977's Arnold: The Education
of a Bodybuilder.
Arnold Schwarzenegger can't stay still.
He's conquered bodybuilding, Hollywood, and
California politics.
When it comes to his actual acting skills
though, he's never really worked to better
them, as his screen presence is powered by
sheer charisma.
"Oh, excuse me.
I forgot to tell you.
This is my ferret."
Stallone not only takes his acting more seriously,
but he also has plenty of clout for offscreen
work.
In addition to being nominated for the Academy
Award twice for playing Rocky Balboa, he also
delivered a powerful performance as a PTSD-stricken
Vietnam vet in First Blood, and he even stole
the show from Robert De Niro, Harvey Keitel,
and Ray Liotta in James Mangold's criminally
under-appreciated Cop Land.
Stallone is also accomplished off-camera,
having screenplay credits on more than 25
TV shows or movies, and directing credits
for eight films.
Sure, some of his creative efforts are genuinely
horrible -- such as 1983's Saturday Night
Fever sequel Staying Alive, which earned 0%
on Rotten Tomatoes -- but hey, even Spielberg
and Scorsese have had duds.
With several Rocky, Rambo, and Expendables
films in his oeuvre, Stallone is an accomplished
and bankable action director, with $1.3 billion
in global grosses for just eight films.
Besides being one of only a few movie stars
who started his career as a world-class athlete,
Schwarzenegger boasts another — arguably
even more impressive — accomplishment.
He's one of only three actors to become governor
of a state.
Schwarzenegger was elected to succeed the
recalled Democrat Gray Davis, serving as the
Republican governor of California from 2003-2011.
Schwarzenegger told The Hollywood Reporter
he also would've run for president in 2016,
but he was unable to because the Constitution
forbids foreign-born people from serving as
president.
The only other actor-governor left to mention
is Schwarzenegger's memorable Predator co-star
Jesse Ventura, who served as governor of Minnesota
from 1999-2003.
While Stallone would win our vote if he ran
for pretty much anything, only Schwarzenegger
has served as governor of America's most populous
state.
Star power is hard to quantify, or even define.
You could be the most talented actor, the
most beautiful person, or the most charismatic
performer, but that's no guarantee anybody
is going to buy a ticket to watch your movie.
Whatever star power is, you either have it,
or you don't.
Stallone and Schwarzenegger both do, in spades.
But who has more?
There's really only one signifier that matters
in Hollywood — who's made more money at
the box office.
By that standard, the winner is clearly Stallone.
Stallone's career box office total is $2.8
billion domestic and $6.3 billion worldwide,
beating out Schwarzenegger's career total
of $2.1 billion domestic and $5.4 billion
worldwide.
As massive as those numbers are, they're even
more impressive when you consider they aren't
adjusted for inflation, as both actor's biggest
hits happened more than 25 years ago.
Worth noting, Stallone has been in more movies,
62 films to Schwarzenegger's 44, and Arnold
dropped out of acting while serving as California's
governor from 2003-2011.
However, by that point, both actors were past
their primes as box office draws, so it's
unlikely Schwarzenegger would've starred in
a massive hit during those years.
In fact, his last pre-political role was a
supporting part in the Jackie Chan bomb Around
the World in 80 Days.
Though Stallone's box office total beats Schwarzenegger's,
Arnold takes the cake when it comes to average
earnings.
Stallone's 62 films have earned an average
of $54 million domestically and $112 million
worldwide, while Schwarzenegger's 44 movies
have brought home an average of $60 million
domestically and $135 million worldwide.
While both guys found their greatest success
playing their marquee characters -- Stallone
with Rocky and Rambo and Schwarzenegger with
the T-800, they were also successful in other
roles, proving neither man was a one-hit character
wonder.
So, which matters more — totals or averages?
You'll have to ask the accountants at the
movie studios about that.
All we can say is that during their commercial
peaks, Stallone and Schwarzenegger were money.
You can compare Stallone and Schkwarzenegger
on several tangible, measurable fronts -- from
box office results to career accomplishments
to the size of their respective pecs and biceps.
But there are some metrics where you have
to just go with your heart.
Therefore, we can confidently say that Stallone's
most famous characters, Rocky and Rambo, are
more iconic than Schwarzenegger's, the T-800.
This is subjective, but defensible.
For one, Rocky is the winner of three Academy
Awards, including Best Picture, and it spearheaded
an eight-film franchise, including the Creed
movies, with $1.5 billion in global box office.
While the Rambo films are less critically
acclaimed than Rocky, the five-film franchise
has still earned an impressive $817 million
over five films.
Yes, The Terminator franchise has earned more
-- $2 billion worldwide over six films -- but
one film, Terminator: Salvation, didn't even
star Schwarzenegger, while the last film,
Terminator: Dark Fate, bombed big time.
None of the Rocky or Rambo movies have ever
performed poorly -- whether we're talking
about the box office or review scores.
Schwarzenegger's biggest hit outgrossed Stallone's
by a pretty substantial margin.
With $204 million domestic, Terminator 2:
Judgment Day was the biggest box office hit
in 1991.
Stallone achieved a similar feat in 1976 when
Rocky topped the box office with $117 million,
and he almost did the same thing in 1985 when
Rambo: First Blood Part II earned $150 million
and Rocky IV earned $127 million.
Impressive achievements all around, but Stallone's
biggest hit -- not adjusted for inflation
-- isn't even a Rocky or Rambo movie.
Excluding his cameo in Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol. 2, Stallone's biggest grosser is the
$311 million worldwide that The Expendables
2 earned in 2012.
Not bad, but still less than $200 million
of what T2 earned worldwide 20 years earlier.
Besides, Schwarzenegger also had a prominent
role in Stallone's biggest hit, The Expendables
2.
Talk about bragging rights!
Part of being a successful movie star isn't
just thriving during the big hits — it's
surviving the big bombs.
One thing we can say for Sylvester Stallone
is that he didn't star in one of the most
significant bombs in Hollywood history, Batman
& Robin.
Schwarzenegger did, but we doubt he regrets
that decision, as he netted a cool $25 million
for playing Mr. Freeze.
We think $25 million for less than one month's
work was a worthy price to pay for killing
the Batman franchise, though we doubt Warner
Brothers was too pleased with the investment.
Ironically, Batman & Robin is actually not
Schwarzenegger's worst movie -- see The Villain,
which earned a horrid 0% Tomatometer score
-- but it is his most notorious.
It's also one of the most influential superhero
movies of all time, and not in a good way,
as it ended one of the biggest hit franchises
ever, the Burton-Schumacher Batman films.
Plus, it sent the Dark Knight into exile until
Christopher Nolan brought him back eight years
later in Batman Begins.
Stallone has some stinkers, no doubt, but
he's never killed a multi-billion franchise
and still made millions doing it.
As Rocky tells his son in 2006's Rocky Balboa:
"It ain't about how hard you can hit.
It's about how hard you can get hit and keep
moving forward.
How much you can take and keep moving forward."
Make no mistake, moviegoers and critics gave
Stallone a stiff right hook to the jaw with
the 1992 comedy Stop!
Or My Mom Will Shoot.
With a 7% critic's score and 21% audience
score on Rotten Tomatoes and $26.6 million
worldwide, it's Stallone's biggest career
misfire.
Yes, with a 4% Tomatometer score, Reach Me
is technically his worst movie, but that ensemble
dramedy was a misguided if noble defeat that
only saw limited release in 2014.
Stop!
Or My Mom Will Shoot was supposed to be a
hit!
What was Stallone thinking?
Turns out, it was Schwarzenegger.
According to a Q&A on Instagram, Stallone
claimed Schwarzenegger tricked him into doing
the part by making Stallone think he was interested.
He wasn't, and it's easy to see why.
While Schwarzenegger had success in action-comedies
like Twins, Kindergarten Cop, and Jingle All
the Way, Stallone's biggest failure was in
trying to beat Arnold at his own game.
Stallone learned the hard way, you don't play
politics with Schwarzenegger.
It's one of the most coveted places in all
of Hollywood.
More than a table at Musso and Frank's or
courtside seats next to Jack Nicholson at
a Los Angeles Lakers home game, it's top billing.
To be listed first above the movie's title
is an absolute statement about star power,
and so naturally, it's inspired numerous squabbles
among movie stars.
When it comes to our two actors in question,
Sylvester Stallone has always gotten top billing
over Arnold Schwarzenegger.
This wasn't a surprise in The Expendables,
as Arnold had an uncredited cameo, while Stallone
wrote, directed, and starred in it.
Stallone again got top billing in The Expendables
2 and The Expendables 3, while Arnold got
an "and Schwarzenegger" credit, a respectable
position given his minor supporting role.
But in 2013's Escape Plan, with just Stallone
and Schwarzenegger as above-the-title leads,
Stallone got top billing.
Sure, the movie bombed with $103 million worldwide
on a $70 million budget, but that's beside
the point.
When it comes to billing, Stallone has always
come out on top.
We've compared and contrasted Stallone and
Schwarzenegger in quite a few ways, but one
important one still remains.
Who would win in a fight?
It may not be the most mature way to settle
the debate, but it makes the most sense, given
they're both men whose brands are built on
machismo.
If we're being honest, Schwarzenegger would
win.
For one, Stallone's billed height of 5'10"
is well below Schwarzenegger's 6'2".
And while Stallone is pretty jacked, Schwarzenegger
is one of the greatest bodybuilders of all
time.
Additionally, Arnold was known for his size
and strength.
Sure, Stallone was Rocky Balboa, but convincingly
playing a world-class athlete isn't the same
as being one.
While we'd never want to see them actually
fight, if it ever came time to throw hands,
our money's on Arnold.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
action stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.